thoughts on ukraine to start with
the scenes that we've seen over the
weekend and the images have emerged are
utterly horrifying and sickening i mean
that's why it is right that we work
across parliament to continue to provide
the support the ukrainian government
needs in order to defend their country
and to see withdrawal of russian troops
i mean i do think we should still be
considering what more we can do around
sanctions particularly financial
sanctions
we've seen too much dirty money drifting
into our country in recent years and we
do still need to take more action to
lift that veil of secrecy
around some of these shell companies so
that more assets can be seized in due
course
what about the refugees that are coming
from ukraine it's still only a dribble
really and it should be a tsunami
it's been a very bureaucratic process
that the government have put in place we
think it would have been better just to
have a simple straightforward emergency
visa i mean i've seen cases where even
even where people are seeking to join
family that are already here in the uk
that's been complicated it's taken a
very long time and we and i think that
wider support that's needed around those
who don't have family here it just
hasn't been as fast or as quick as we
would like lots of people have come
forward very generously to provide
support i think we do need to still take
action to speed that process up
domestic politics we are aware that the
first finds have now been issued for
what happened at downing street over a
period of many
events um including
the night before prince philip's funeral
and also hearing that you know they were
belting out karaoke ballads when people
couldn't sing
in church
what is labour's position now on those
that received fines do you feel that
everyone
should
names should be made public just some of
them what about carrie johnson where do
we stop
i'm interested in the actions that
elected politicians have taken in
particular and the role of the prime
minister here i think that's what's most
important because the culture in any
organization starts at the top and we
know that the prime minister's lied he's
lied right throughout this process he
thinks we're all uh we're all fools that
we can't see what's been going on the
fines that have been issued confirm what
we've known for a very long time which
is that while everyone in this country
was doing what was asked of them by the
government staying at home following the
rules making extraordinary sacrifices
not seeing loved ones or going to
funerals in some cases over at downing
street they were having wild parties and
the prime minister knew what was going
on and told parliament otherwise he has
lost all moral authority and is making
our country an international laughing
stock by his continued refusal to be
upfront and honest with the british
people about all of this
um the tories in fact then for in the
form of the welsh sector this morning
saying you need to get over yourself um
there's much more uh important and
distressing things happening in the
world stage and and what happened during
lockdown it's it's over
well they would say that wouldn't they
um but actually decency integrity and
honesty in politics really do matter and
it matters most when you're in a
situation where the prime minister
himself is lying to the british people
and i don't think actually that's where
the public are either you know everyone
was asked to make tremendous sacrifices
during lockdown to get control of the
virus and then to be faced with the
realization that those at the top
running our country thought that the
rules didn't apply to them that they
were above the law i think is staggering
and speaks volumes about the prime
minister's character
talk to me about labour calling for more
financial support for families needing
child care um
some months that's the least of their
worries at the moment given that they
can't actually heat or
eat
it's part of that wider pressure that
families are facing so yes gas and
electricity bills are skyrocketing the
weekly shop is way up and the cost of
filling up your car has massively
increased but the cost of child care has
also massively gone up as well you know
many parents watching this will know
that the cost of child care is often
greater than the rent or the mortgage
you'll be paying every month that means
for many parents and it's usually women
they end up having to cut back on their
hours or give up work because they just
can't make the child care stack up i
mean that is wrong for families but also
it has a bigger impact on our economy
too
labour's children's fraud
would be
so coming out of the pandemic given the
impact that this has all had on children
we can all see it for ourselves we would
deliver breakfast clubs and after school
activities for all children because
child care and child care needs are not
just about our youngest children
parents are facing growing challenges
with providing health care right
throughout the school day at the end and
the beginning too
um
just before i let you go we did hear
from your colleague jonathan reynolds um
yesterday he was saying that like the
rest of europe we in the uk should start
to prepare for energy
rationing do you agree
we don't think that will be necessary
and it's not what we would want to see
this is primarily an issue of price
rather than one of the play
but of course we do want to see from the
government this term plan our energy
they've had 12 years now we don't have
the energy security that we need as a
country it's why we've been exposed to
these price fluctuations and part of the
reason that families are seeing those
skyrocketing bills i mean that's why
we've said we need to take much more
action around insulating homes many
homes 19 million of them in our country
do not have the right insulation and
energy measures in place and that's
meant that you know over many years not
just with the massive increase we've
seen lately
uh families and pensioners are paying
ever more rising bills and that's having
a real impact so we should take action
on those longer term challenges as well
as that immediate help laborers set out
around up to 600 pounds for those who
need it most with their energy bills
paid for that full tax on on gas
producers